let's check out this first story from
the verge
twitter miscounted its daily users for
three years straight how did this happen
twice yo the verge is a progressive
website when they point out you're doing
something wrong some must be really
wrong they report twitter overstated the
number of daily users on its service for
three years straight over counting by up
to 1.9 million users each quarter the
error was due to twitter inadvertently
counting multiple accounts as active
when they were all tied to a single user
even if they weren't in use these
incorrect usage numbers were given for
q1 2019 through q4 2021 this somehow
this is somehow not the first time
twitter has done this in 2017 twitter
also realized it had been overstating
its user figures by one to two million
for three years the repeat mistake was
revealed today in twitter's earnings
release for the first quarter of 2022.
here's the amazing thing the earnings
report was bad
they were they were down a bit i think
was it like 30 million less they uh it
was let me just pull the timcast.com
article twitter's earnings report shows
missed revenue projections
they were they were uh projecting 1.23
billion making only 1.2 billion now
that's not that bad but their money is
going down and i predicted this this
likely in my opinion would have resulted
in a stock drop off but because elon has
already agreed to buy it stock is likely
going up or staying the same in fact the
fact the stock isn't currently sitting
at 54.20 says to me there are some
people who think the deal won't go
through and it's possible but this is
big and it could be a reason so many
people on twitter are now saying this
sounds like fraud yo like twitter was
lying they were lying to their
advertisers and they lied to elon musk i
don't think elon musk would decide not
to buy the platform now but i wonder
what this means for the deal and i
wonder what it means for twitter's
executives if any is anybody going to
get in trouble yeah i mean elon's
ability to negotiate downwards um also
of course let's point out the fact that
twitter which has decided that they
would take it upon themselves to
determine what was or was not
misinformation in the outside world
would not even deliver accurate figures
on how their website was doing i'll tell
you man i work behind the scenes at
mines developing that company for a
decade and there is no way that they did
not know that one person with five
accounts is not one person they they're
intentionally allowing that to play for
for to overvalue the company this is
insidious let's let's let's drag i don't
know that for sure of course i can't i
can't prove that let's drive this point
home ian you were a co-founder at
mines.com a social media platform with
millions of users yeah you watched
you've seen internals you actually
moderated the platform yeah in your
expert opinion having run social media
infrastructure twitter knew that that
was wrong i bet so there are 7 500 yes
yes they there are so many employees of
that company 7 500 plus employees i
would imagine 30
probably 10 of them knew that's a good
point too
not a single person said hey wait a
minute guys i think if you've got a
company that knows if somebody
misgendered somebody uh
you know if somebody and that can shut
them down and are that deep into
the daily workings of their site that
they didn't somehow know how many people
were using it as kind of
they might be calculating daily active
logins which is
the dirty game to play because it's the
one person logs into five different
accounts then it's still one person well
i mean look if they couldn't figure out
how many people were using their website
all i have to say is they need to learn
to code
that's a fair point i knew somebody was
gonna say that yeah we're waiting for it
yeah they do need to learn that but but
uh uh
i don't know what happens does anything
happen is i mean look we're seeing a lot
of victories across the board but does
anybody really believe someone will be
held accountable for this stuff i i
predict that there's gonna be a lot more
that's gonna come out of this closet at
twitter that this is going to be less of
the problem that i think we're going to
find out as far as what's been being
manipulated over the last x amount of
years well as we pointed out earlier you
know in the intro and the other day this
weird conspiracy theory that i think is
backed up by more than enough
circumstantial evidence to say there
should be a probe i believe it should be
a criminal investigation
because uh jack dorsey as well i i can't
remember who else but i'm pretty sure
other people from twitter have testified
before congress under oath i'm pretty
sure they're all under oath right yep as
saying they did not have political blocs
or anything like that
now we're seeing serious circumstantial
evidence that that was not true
of course
i'm not confident anybody would do
anything about it well during the
hacking when we were talking about the
day the blue checks disappeared there
was screenshots that were sent out that
showed there was a box to click for
shadow banding like that was a real
thing that got out that they kind of you
know whisked away and but there was a
lot of there's a lot of stuff that did
come up after that popped up that they
showed these screenshots um i mean the
bigger day was that it had been hacked
but then there were all of these
screenshots that popped up that there
was this this you know console that
showed uh
that there was an ability to kind of
quiet certain users here here's the game
they play though so if we if we go back
to 2018 with the story from end gadget
twitter's shadow banning bug unfairly
filtered six hundred thousand accounts
jack dorsey confirms this
they say you know our algorithms were
unfairly filtering six hundred thousand
accounts including some members of
congress from our search autocomplete
but how did it happen blah blah blah
blah blah you know what they would say
but it was not political but it is
the game they'll play is
right now uh elon musk he posted the
meme of me and vijaya gaday and it's
like the circle where it's like here's
left in bias
and a bunch of leftists were like is
misgendering really political they're
arguing that
purposefully dead naming someone is
political and i'm like it is
it is not a moral statement
conservatives do not agree with your
view and define things differently it is
inherently political
they don't accept that so they argue
it's not political so then they'll say
well we're talking about pronoun use has
nothing to do with politics right well
they're completely full of it they know
that referring to something is
non-political is just a useful
rhetorical tool so everything is
political exactly so they'll say
everything is political but then when it
comes to something they want to be taken
for granted they'll say this isn't
political human rights aren't political
it's like well actually the reason a
political system exists to a large
extent is for us to figure out on a
political scale how we treat each other
so yes it is but also most of these
mistakes that if you look back to over
the years that were happening just
coincidentally were happening to
conservatives i mean
you didn't see like sir uh sank and uh
all these giant liberals on the right on
the left you know their their accounts
being
shadow banned or losing people or being
for that matter being suspended for
anything the the red-headed libertarian
good friend of ours josie that's her
twitter follow her at t r h l official
she was banned on january 20th
of 2021 and reinstated abruptly this
year randomly on tuesday and she said
this has has this happened to any
prominent left-wing profile no
not a single one have has anybody seen
any anybody look i follow people on the
left i interact with them i have not
seen a single person on the left be like
whoa my account was just brought back
that's so weird i've never met a person
in the left that had their account
suspended yeah everyone brought well
there are so there were a handful of
people anti-war oh yeah well anti-war
anti-establishment leftists they got
nuked that's funny or people on the left
who were part of that rare breed that
actually spoke out against the coveted
restrictions right right
yeah the uh several people from occupy
wall street had their accounts nuked and
i think it was because
what we're really seeing is
establishment versus anti-establishment
and because
the people associated with the sphere of
influence of the right order we want to
call it our anti-establishment they're
more likely to get hit but there there
were so uh project veritas did an expose
and they found that um i think it's live
action is it's right live action that
would be lila rose's group yes they were
being censored by i think it was
pinterest
that's right but in that black list i
think it was pinterest in the blacklist
was also um anti-media i think it was
one of these anti-war groups it was
anti-media groups it was anti-media and
uh uh scott scott horton he's from no
it's he's anti-war
okay so the anti-media guys are like
fairly anti-war and i said hey that's a
big deal too
i think what's really happening is if if
you are in line with the establishment
they don't care in what capacity right
you're protected
so being pro-war
look at look at these conservatives i'm
doing air quotes who are staunchly
pro-war and align themselves with
democrats they're all fine yeah exactly
like i don't think liz cheney's going to
get shadow banned any time soon i don't
think anyone was ever concerned about
that for her
you guys think that corporations should
be allowed to blacklist social media
networks no well what do you mean by
that have like behind the scenes uh
lists that they can put you on that why
not change the way that you see the
network it depends on the network i
suppose i think the change has to come
once a platform reaches a certain size
so if if you have a blog that reaches a
hundred thousand people and it's like
you know a cowboy living blog and you
allow people to post their cowboy
stories i think it makes sense to be
like hey it can only be cowboy stuff but
if you have twitter which markets itself
to everyone
and it's open to all to have you know
the free speech of the free speech party
and then you start deciding no no no at
that point it's there's something bad
going on i mean there were rulings that
when trump was banning people when he
was president that he had to unban them
i think right there was a case so i mean
i think the courts are getting to a
point where the courts eventually are
going to weigh in on this that you know
a town square
certainly has a certain level of
protection that i think is kind of just
weight making its way through
the system but we'll get there yeah and
you know trump wasn't even banning
people he was just blocking blocking
that's why i meant blocking no it's true
but also we were talking about this i
believe two episodes ago but that would
be pretty in line with the decision of
martial alabama again i'm no lawyer but
it was basically decided by the supreme
court in 1946 that even if you own a
company town and it's your own private
property if you open yourself up to the
public square to a large enough extent
you have to import the first amendment
basically or the civil rights that would
be due to the people in that
jurisdiction
i think that makes sense
what about verizon
and verizon now phone companies yeah
public no it's they're a common care
utility they shouldn't be allowed to do
that they should have to they should
have to provide service but you know
they do they play dirty games so a t
wouldn't let me open an account unless i
gave them cash up front
and i was like i have literally no i
don't want att that bad i was you know
because um when we when when you when
you travel you want multiple networks so
uh particularly we have a cellular
bonding unit for when we're on the road
that combines a bunch of different cell
signals into one that we can do better
broadcast stuff so i said the best thing
to do is to get multiple networks to
avoid congestion and at t was like oh
you can you can sign up here but you got
to give a 600 bucks up front
and then i was like you want me to give
you 600 bucks in cash right now just to
sign up and then what happens that money
we hold it like i don't need your
service dude but that's one thing they
do to block you so imagine imagine you
make 20 bucks an hour
can you afford to make a deposit that
large is what they do to poor people to
say we're not blocking them from the
service we just need a security deposit
which blocks them from the service i
don't think you would need a lot of
these laws and stuff if people that's
why i think when musk put that you know
the poll out do you feel that this is a
fair and it was 70 percent no to free
speech i think most americans are kind
of even keeled and
they can see i think if both sides felt
that they were being treated fairly
there would be no problem that's not
possible right right and the the issue
is i'd like you all to imagine something
imagine there is a big sphere of water
and there's a right side of it and a
left side of it at some point a small
bud started to emerge on the left side
and get bigger it got bigger and bigger
and bigger until it eventually butted
off and flopped onto the ground
that same sphere still has a left and a
right but now there's this new sphere
right multicultural democracy staring at
its parent constitutional republic
so
that that budded sphere of influence
doesn't care for principles or morals it
wants power it wants to grow
it will never be satisfied so there's no
making it happen elon musk says he wants
everyone to be you know equally happy or
upset i'm like ain't gonna happen
usually when the buds fall off the tree
gets they get eaten by like a zebra who
walks away and poops it out somewhere
else that's how the trees spread their
seed so maybe that's i think it's
withering i think i think what we're
seeing now with twitter and panic with
these weird algorithmic changes with cnn
plus collapsing with joy reid losing her
job with j with cordon was james corden
quitting with all of these things what
we're seeing is that it can't survive on
its own it butted off but it has no
source of energy and so people like
genkuger and brian stelter and all these
people who decided to join that sphere
are now watching the walls close in on
them as it dries out as its life energy
is evaporating all around it unable to
sustain itself and they'll regret it
well i think it has to do with also like
ratings it's it's there has to be anger
and a reason for people to come to
something and if you look at ratings on
msnbc versus cnn you know if there's a
giant terror attack you're guaranteed
that cnn's going to beat everyone
because people run to these things and i
think that
these types of these types of
products
pull people towards it and you know
there was a giant people
there were a lot of people invented
during the trump era that fed off of the
rage thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you